welcome to Kyrgyzstan a central asian
republic demeter douche anova runs a
snack stand here near the remains of the
ancient Silk Road
tamara has cooked this lamb and beef
until it's soft now she's cutting it
into small strips no Wayne estas loco a
lot of people come through here Jillian
terminal God the fashion we get a lot of
foreigners tourists people on holiday
business is good that's why we chose
this spot where the moon is a syllable
day the second main ingredient in this
national dish is noodles they're mixed
with onions and the beef and lamb now
for the final touch the most important
part of this dish is the broth it's made
as de Mirabeau oils the meat off the
bones just a little more meat and the
best pramukh is ready to it up wrong
with you
luckily i put submission button up a big
plate of fish pond muck like this costs
150 song that's about 250 in Euros we
charge foreigners 200 songs on CD ste
just kidding best remark is Kyrgyz for
eat with five fingers it's the country's
most popular dish and you don't need a
knife and fork to enjoy it this customer
obviously didn't get the message but
fish pramukh tastes great whether you
use your fingers or silverware yeah yes
on my love meat beshbarmak has lots of
it that's why I love it you can get the
burrito a meal like this will fortify
any traveler for the next stage of their
journey